موضوعنا التالي مفاجئ الحقيقه عندما تسمع
احد يكيل السباب للاخر قد تعتقد انه عصبي
او يعاني من ضغوط نفسيا مثلا لكن وفق
خبراء في علم الادراك والسلوك فان هذا
الشخص اكثر راحه نفسيه بل يستخدم طريقه
بديله عن العنف الجسدي
الدراسه الامريكيه مشاهدينا التي نتحدث
عنها اليوم
تشير جانب غريب من الشتائم وهو ان لها
بالفعل فوائد ليس فقط في تهدئه الاعصاب بل
ايضا تمنح القدره على تحمل الالم ايضا
الباحثون ذكروا في دراساتهم او في دراستهم
كلمات الكاتب الامريكي الساخر ماركت وين
الذي كان على صواب عندما قال انه في ظل
ظروف معينه يمكن ان توفر الالفاظ البذيئه
الراحه اذا في الها فوائد السبات على ما
يبدو على كل حال هذه الفوائد راح نتابعها
مع زميلنا علاء سرحان التي تكشفها دراسه
تحديدا وبعد ذلك سنعود لفتح هذا الملف
على
علماء النفس والادراك الذين درسوا تاريخ
الشتائم يشيرون الى انها ظهرت منذ ايام
رجل الكهف الاول واصبحت النساء تميل الان
الى الشتائم بنفس القدر مع الرجال واحيانا
اكثر منهم يكشف تقرير الخبير الشهير في
الالفاظ النابيه واستاذ علم النفس يتم في
ان الكلمات البذيئه مفيده في مجمل
السيناريوهات على سبيل المثال تحمل المزيد
من الالم فقد اظهر المتطوعون الذين وضعوا
ايديهم في الثلج اظهروا قدره اكبر على
التحمل عندما اطلقوا الشتائم في التجربه
كذلك تزيد القوه البدنيه باستخدام
البداءات في تجربه اجريت عام 2018 اكتشف
باحثون ان قوه قبضه اليد كانت اكبر بين
المشاركين الذين كرروا الشتائم بل يجد
العلم ايضا ان الاشخاص الذين يشتمون اكثر
جداره
[موسيقى]
يعني الفوائد مش بس يعادل بانك يعني تاخد
راحتك وتفش خلقك الشتائم ولكن يكون افضل
لو بتالف شتائم هيك دراسه عم تحكي مش انا
بتالف شتائم جديد
من العراق سالنا الناس ما رايك في دراسه
تقول ان الشتائم تهدئ الاعصاب ماذا اجابه
نهائيا ما له علاقه اكو طرق ثانيه يعني
غير الشتم والسب وغيره فيقدر يهدي اعصابه
بيها او يسكت اصلا يعني ليش والله تعتمد
على الشخص يعني هو حسب الشخص واهلي شلون
تربى بيها يتعلم من المقابيل بس هي بشكل
عام يعني مو ضروري يعني هذا الشيء يعني مو
ضروري حتى الانسان يهدا مو صحيح هذا يعني
راح تاثر سلبه مستقبلا حتى لو كان شخص
يعني غلطان بحقك الشتيمه مرحله تكون حل
سلبي
صحيح يعني اعصابه انا مرات عصبيه
لا غلط مو يعني شتى امي تهداء عصابه بس هو
يعني يصور هاي الطريقه يعني هو هو يتخيل
هذا الشيء انه راح اعتبره اعصابه وبعد ما
يستقر
[موسيقى]
والله احسب الدراسه انا يعني ما اعتقد
يصير يعني
عصبي كلش ارتاح شويه اشرب مي اشوف يعني
واغلط لا ما اعتقد الاعصاب اكيد لا يعني
هذا رده فعل وكل كلمه وتصرف يحكي يتندم
عليه فيكون لازم يعني بارد بهذا الموضوع
وما يحكي
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم الينا استشاريها الصحه
النفسيه الدكتور وليد هندي دكتور وليد
صباح الخير
صباح العربيه عليكم وعلى كل الامه العربيه
يا صباح السعاده دكتور انا مش ذاكر اسم
الممثل لكن هو بيقول فيلم كله ضرب ضرب
مفيش شتيمه هل الشتيمه احيانا بالفعل هي
فتره تنفيس عن غضب من الممكن ان تهدينا
بالفعل الشتيمه الواحد لما بيقولها في
اعنتها او في السياقها او لما تكون رد فعل
الموقف ضاغط على الانسان بتبقى شكل من
اشكال التنفيس الانفعالي بتعمل ازاحه
للمكبوتات فاحيان كتير الانسان فينا لما
بيجي يشتم حد مش بيشتمه انما هو بيوثقه في
لفظ معين بيجسد كل معانيه في السلوكيات
والغير مرغوبه وبالتالي حتى بتخف من
وطاهقه السلوك العدواني يعني بدل ما يعمل
رد فعل عدواني فبيكتفي بالشتيمه او ينعته
بلفظ او اتنين ومش شرط على فكره الشتيمه
تبقى في المواجهه يعني ممكن انا يحصل لي
موقف ضاغط فنوع من السوشيال اكشن او
التكيف الاجتماعي مع الذات احكي لحد في
مكالمه تليفون او في حديث مرسل بيني وبينه
وانعد حد بلفظ غير مرغوب فالشتيمه احيان
كثير بتدي نوع من التكيف ازاحه المكبوتات
رفع الضغوط بتديك شعور بالكفاءه النفسيه
وفي احيان كتير كمان احنا بنشتم كنوع من
التغلب على بعض المخاوف المرضيه يمكن حتى
كان فيه برنامج للمقالب شهير جدا في رمضان
كنا بنشوف الضيوف اول حاجه يعملوها كانوا
يتوجهوا بالشتائم اللي كان بيستضيفهم ليه
بيتغلبوا على مخاوفهم المرضيه بلس ان
التقرير اشار لحته مهمه جدا ان هي بتزيد
من قوه الانسان في مواجهه الالم نتيجه ان
الواحد لما بيجي يشتم بيرتفع عنده
الادرينالين بيتراجع الدوبامين وبناء عليه
بيبقى عنده قوه
بتختلف عن اقراننا عاديين اللي هم ممكن ما
بيشتموش
جميل انك فسرت لنا شو بصير بالدماغ من
ناحيه هرمونات ادرينالين دوبامين وما الى
ذلك هلا احنا شفنا راي الشارع العراقي
واللي حابه اساله هو عن خصوصيه المجتمعات
العربيه لمحافظه اكثر ويعني غير مقبول
السباب والشتائم بشكل عام فيها وللنساء
حتى بشكل خاص ربما بدرجه اكثر هل الموضوع
بيختلف وهي الدراسه بما انها دراسه
امريكيه قد لا تنطبق على مجتمعاتنا
العربيه
ام انه هي طبيعه انسانيه يعني خلينا نتفق
احنا بنقيد الدراسه بنقيد نتائج الدراسه
مش بنقيد الشتيمه يعني تاييدنا النتائج
الدراسه من الناحيه العلميه لا يعني ان هي
تبقى دعوه لاطلاق السباب والقذائف
بالمناسبه الشتيمه مش في كل الاحيان
بتعني ان انا بقول الفاظ اخلاقي غير
اخلاقيه هي ممكن تقول الفاظ غير مرغوبه ده
نمره واحد نمره اتنين حضرتك الانترنت
دلوقتي بقى له لغه خاصه في الشتائم يعني
لغه خاصه كده فرانكو عرب بيستعينوا بها
الشباب وهم بيكتبوا على الشات فما يقدرش
نتجاهل الظاهره ودي مهمه بس مش معنى كده
ان احنا نخليها على المشاعل سبب بسيط جدا
لان الانسان لو قعد يشتم على طول هنا
هيوشار اليه ببعض الصفات الغير مرغوبه قد
يعرض للتجنب الاجتماعي فاحيانا كثير ممكن
يفقد المركز الوظيفي بتاعه يعني بيبقى
يوصل بوصمه غير مرغوبه وهكذا فاحنا بنقول
دكتور
لازم اسالك السؤال
والله خلصنا الوقت يعني الزملاء بيضغطوا
لكن خليني اسالك بانه احيانا ليس فقط في
حاله
ربما غضب احيانا حتى لما تشوف شيء جميل
الواحد ممكن منظر جميل وحده حلوه يعني
يخرب بيت كده البنت جميله دي او الى الى
ما الى الى اخره هل هذا ايضا يعتبر من
الصحه النفسيه
يعني هو يعني ان الله جميل يحب الجمال
فممكن بس اختلاف التعبير عن الجمال
باختلاف الثقافات والبيئات الاجتماعيه
يعني كل طبقه اجتماعيه بيبقى لها لغه
تعبير ولغه تواصل لفظي في تعبيراتها تجاه
الاخر وهكذا بس انا عاوزه اشير لحاجه مهمه
جدا ايوه احنا عندنا متلازمه نفسيه اسمها
متلازمه البزاءه دي متلازمه اسمها توريت
بيبقى جين فيها خلل في الجين الوراثي
بتخلي الانسان يشتم ياتي بايحاءات ولغه
جسد مختلفه وبالتالي ممكن تكون حاله مرضيه
غير الانسان اللي هو العادي ويمكن في
مشاهير في العالم عندهم متلازمه توريت كان
على راسهم مزارع على سبيل المثال والتمويل
جونسون اتكتب البريطاني الشهير يعني
دلوقتي لو حد عنده هذه المتلازمه
لا يعني حتى لو اشتكوا عليه يطلع براءه مع
هذه
الدكتور لا دكتور وليد هندي استشاري
الصحه النفسيه شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من
القاهره والله يديم هذه الابتسامه الجميله
ان شاء الله لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات